what's up what's up everybody Welcome to
the corridor
cast the corridor cast Jake just stopped
playing banj for
intros dude I stopped playing the vanjo
ages ago you know why CU you it was a
little what were you going to say what
were you going to say I was because I
don't know CU your taste improved I
don't know the Bano is a delightful M
instrument I actually quite like it it's
like the double pedals of guitars
the banjo is like when it's not in the
right setting you know when you bring it
into a podcast setting it's kind of like
a bull in a china shop you know it's
it's just it's just kind of everywhere
and it's it's wreaking havoc um which is
why I would only just play a couple
chords but it does sort of grab your
attention but I don't know if it grab
your I don't know if it grabs your
attention in a way that is conducive to
you know like an audio experience yeah
when you come to a podcast perhaps I
don't know I I found it delightful okay
look I like my hot I can always bring it
back yeah bring it back please direct
request right here from a person sitting
on this other side of the screen guys if
Nico wants it you know n get
wants he just pulls it into
frame materializes no I it's downstairs
I do have my guitar over there but um
okay next podcast I guess yeah I can um
let me rering it it needs to be restring
I have the I have the strings they're
they're all nice and presentable and you
show me that banjo Jake okay and it'll
just be a
little
yeah so I have a I have a uh inspiration
question for you
guys so making a lot of YouTube videos
been doing it for 14 years something
like that a long time
um you know there's a thing that we
always say especially on visual effects
artist react which is you know it needs
to serve the story it's like I had this
crazy idea for movie and we came up with
a way to pull it off and that required
us to invent this new magic trick and
we're like wow it's always such a cool
magic trick when that happens right it
needs to serve the
story but when I look back at the videos
that we've done in Corridor and like
various shorts and things that I've
actually said in our videos a lot of our
videos come from having an effect we
want to try and then we write a story
for that
effect now is that a backwards way to be
going about doing this because we've had
some pretty solid results going in that
direction like it's been an inspiration
that's led us to do some cool things is
that saying of the VFX need to be made
for the story is that really a true
saying or in reality can you have a cool
VFX technique that you then write a
story around and have a good story from
that well I feel like it's the it's the
prompt that then leads you to do this
write the story but then the story
becomes the Bible mhm it's it's cuz like
creativity there's no limitations you
could do anything but once you have an
effect that you want to achieve you go
oh okay maybe we can narrow down our the
window of Stories We want to tell uh I
think that's like kind of how James
Cameron goes about writing movies is
he's like he has a cool scene in mind
and then he's like okay what would be
the story around this but then he starts
going on that and then he's like okay
now I have my story and sometimes that
cool action scene might not make it in
but it's just like the jumping off point
like because there's a fair amount of
like movies and TV shows out there that
have have a story and a visual idea that
go hand in hand and like the story
wouldn't exist the way it does without
the visual idea like you like Birdman
being a one take movie yeah like that if
the one take was irrelevant to the
quality of the Birdman story they
wouldn't have done it like it needs that
cinematic trick to be paired with the
story to make that movie what it is you
know so I don't knowe
um of course it depends on the story I
think um I I think the reason why people
maybe initially turned off to this uh
like approach of coming up with a visual
style and then telling a story with it
is maybe because it doesn't work as
often
MH uh I don't know why that is perhaps
it's just the simply simply the scale
that most television shows and movies
operate at it's that wouldn't really be
how you would go about it you know like
yeah imagine if you were like hey so um
imagine if you're the first person to
like discover a first person camera rig
and you were like oh this is dope we go
to we got to film something with this
but then instead of going out and
shooting like a viral video or like
Superman with a GoPro which is what we
did with it you you go out and you're
like let's do a movie I mean they kind
of did this called hardcore Henry dude
that movie is sick yeah awes that movie
is sick okay so then my theory fails my
theory totally fails um yeah trying I'm
trying to think about it I'm trying to
reverse engineer it you know the
psychology of it yeah because the more I
think about it the more it's like
there's some great pieces of Cinema that
start because somebody's like hey I can
do a cool effect and every's like oh
what's a good story that uses that
effect it's like this maybe and they're
like oh yeah and then it comes out
every's like dang this is groundbreak
like yeah it just seems like that maybe
that saying of story first is like we
just take for granted maybe it's not
quite this I feel like you're getting at
it which is that film is a visual art
form and like uh you know if you just
have a a great story you want to tell
you could probably just write that right
but if
there's like spectacle is baked in with
the story like it's it's all
part of why we engage with with film and
animation is because we also want to be
we want to we want to like experience a
story that uh takes us places and and
has us meet people that we've never met
before but we also want to like
literally see things we've never seen
before that like the novelty of it is
still super important um okay I've got
another theory I'm sorry maybe it's
because that's not how we approach
things in real life you can do it in the
form you can go hey I've got this idea
of you know we're going to come up with
a story to to fit this visual style
that's groundbreaking and then overall
the whole thing will be
groundbreaking but in real life when
we're trying to solve a human problem
it's always the other way which is
here's our here's our story we're
bumping along you know we're arguing
along the way and then we get to a
problem and we're like shoot what do we
do we got to come up with a solution and
we're like let's build a dam and we'll
create hydroelectric power okay good
idea all right well and you know and
it's like it works more in practice that
way I don't know I'm just trying to
think of the psychology behind it in
real life you're right the solutions do
follow the problems and generally in
that order whereas in movies sometimes
are the other way around I mean part of
why I'm asking this is because you know
by the time this podcast comes out our
the Starfield video have come out and
the Starfield video is interesting
because it initially started as this
experiment to see how much further
Across The Uncanny Valley we could get
compared to like our previous
experiences and kind of like what's been
done out there especially like the Indie
Creator level and you know we were
putting together some various like ideas
because you know I've messing with this
pixie face morph stuff uh Unreal Engine
had just announced um or not announced
they had just released you know new face
motion capture tools um you know we had
the new Roco suit in like so we had all
these new Tools in front of us
everything that you know from face
rendering to motion capture to like you
know all all the sorts of stuff Sam's
Dreamland right Sam's Dreamland and it's
like well let's come back to this this
thing and like doing doing faces is
incred like not just faces doing human
characters and CGI is is very difficult
um as we have said a billion times uh
before
um so we're we're putting all these
pieces together and we're we're working
on this project and in the middle of
this project is this Starfield short
that we didn't have that short when we
started this project right it was it was
hey let's come up with something that
uses CGI people in fact I think the
first idea was a parody on the sixth
sense where uh there's a kid who can see
fake people and then the person he's
been talking to has been fake the whole
time and doesn't know it and just like
you know what Bruce Willis everybody is
that the Green Screen Man concept I
don't know yes where everything
everything is done by it's a very deep
cut VFX joke though also a joke which is
not exactly timely um anyway so we
didn't do that idea that idea never got
realized um but this Starfield idea
popped up because Sam's like well it's
so easy to make that stuff in Unreal
Engine like there's a billion kits out
there of like these different things and
like kit bash just you know hooked us up
with some new stuff as well and they
have an amazing sci-fi universe that you
can build and he and Jordan Allen did
this like basically this improv skit
about just you know it's the end of the
world the final battle and the main
character has no idea what's going on
because he doesn't care he's just been
following way points and objective
markers and like you know the other
person who's in this world reacts to
that as one should when the other person
has not been paying attention um and
they did this little skit and like
turned out into this like turned into
this really Charming short and while we
were working on this project at the
beginning I distinctly remember Sam
saying it's like we can't just do we
can't just use the tech for the sake of
using the tech we can't just make a
short about the tech we need to do what
we say we're always going to do and have
a creative idea that we want to execute
and then we solve the problems that we
need in order like you know in order to
be able to execute on that creative idea
and that's where the the tech comes in
and I was like yeah but now I look back
in this process and like that's not at
all what actually happened what actually
happened was we started playing with
tech and then went went what's a cool
story we can write using all this Tech
and then we got a really cool thing out
of it so just it was a it's weird it
feels like it's been backwards but at
the same time the results have been
delightful for the most part every time
we've done it yeah it it you know you
look at yeah especially the corridor
videos
and yeah there's no bright line rule I
mean even the Assassin's Creed 3 video
that we did like I don't know how many
years ago it was 10 years ago our first
that was a brand integration and so the
reason why we came up with that
initially was they said hey we want you
guys to come up with a
story in the Assassin's Creed universe
so it's not like we went to them and
pitched them because we had this great
story about a character or characters in
The Assassin's Creed universe and we
wanted to tell it they came to us and
said hey would you want to tell a story
in the universe and then we came up with
it that way so but it didn't hurt it
that video did great great it's got like
15 million views or whatever and it was
really fun to make and yeah it's one of
our best videos I think it's what you
have to decide like what you think is
backwards like is it backwards just
because we have the tech at our disposal
and then we create based off of what we
had have versus let's create something
and then figure out how to do it like
some people might think that's a
backwards way of doing it cuz it's like
oh you might go over budget and you have
to go well now we're climbing this
different ladder when really maybe we're
doing it right this whole time I I don't
know it's if we have it and it's like a
lot of it is sometimes on the cheaper
side or given to us or used for
experimental purposes and then you
create something so beautiful out of it
it's like is it backwards or is it just
a really cool way of doing
things yeah I mean I definitely find
that constraints being creativity like
more so than anything else like every
time we have a brand say like hey make a
video about this we're like oh how do we
come up with a cool video
in tell there's just too many okay and
then and then you get to the breaking
point and then you're just like no I'm
not doing this I'm not doing this I
can't do you think the same thing
happens when you have a story and then
you have to change your story because
you can't do something because you also
you don't have the tech right rather
than getting in front of it to begin
with then you build something around
what you know that yeah there's some I
think there is something that does
happen when you have an approach you
have a stylistic
approach that doesn't necessarily happen
when you have an idea and that is the
ability
to really precisely tailor the idea to
fit the stylistic approach um and
sometimes when you have an idea and
you're trying to come up with a
stylistic approach to fit that idea that
process can be very
messy um a lot of you know tests
experiments research and devel velopment
da da da da da to try to sort of like
bring everything that's possible into
this particular
Vision but when you have it the other
way it does allow you to be very precise
about story um because you can go well
we know we know what it looks like so we
just need to write within those confines
to and I and I think
that can lend itself
towards less messiness when you're
coming up with an idea I mean I'll give
you an example uh when we were doing
that um Black Rifle coffee uh like
action scene in The Bass Pro
Shop um we we did this thing where there
was this big fight in a Bass Pro Shop it
was super fun um but one of the
conditions of the story like the one of
the one of the precepts of why they were
in the store to begin with was that it
was a Black Friday sale and there was a
bunch of people standing out side of a
bass pro shop and then a riot breaks out
cuz it's Black Friday and then they got
to go and they got to steal the coffee
and get out of there and so it was like
it it all made sense like why did a
fight break out in the middle of a
department store well there was a riot
because people were standing outside for
Black Friday yeah everyone was going
crazy for the products and yeah yeah
everyone was going crazy for the product
so it it all made sense in this little
you know in the in the like two shots
you have to give the backstory in in a
60 second bit um but then the location
came along and said oh well you know
it's we can't have we can't have any
like give any notion that there's a riot
in our
stores and so we we we kind of like
casually took the note and said oh well
we'll come up with something but the
entire
idea rested on this like sort of setting
and so we recontextualized it it wasn't
as good though because it didn't make as
much it didn't have as much impact I
think from like the start and had we had
it been one of those situations where we
had a visual style that we were trying
to achieve then it probably would have
never been a pro some a problem like
that probably would have never Arisen in
the first place because we would have
been writing
for the execution of the visual and not
for a story idea that we had and then
sort of fitting the tools that we had
available to to
that
yeah yeah I don't know
it's I feel like I always get the best
inspiration when I have like a challenge
or a new technique in front of me and
it's something to persue yeah you know
that's something that's very unique
about film making in that way because
it's like if you're uh if you paint with
oil paints it's not like oh they just
came out with a new oil paint dude they
out the new hea blue going to paint this
peacock but even then like I think
people who do you know the Manual Arts
illustration all that stuff they still
there will be some kind of CH because
you can draw anything but like you need
some some limitation some some narrowing
of of what you can do creatively to
actually like make something come alive
or to like find the idea cuz I like the
idea that like the the perfect version
of the idea exists out there somewhere
and you're like trying to find it and if
you're starting with with no you know
sort of like narrowing lens of your
vision you it's really hard to find it
but if you start to kind of like narrow
down your search field you can kind of
spot the idea and there's you know an
unlimited amount of quote perfect ideas
but like you have to find the specific
one know it's the same way in um in
music too A lot of times I mean
sometimes you get a song in your head
and you just have to write the song out
but other times you'll be learning
guitar or piano we were just talking
about this before we started the podcast
you learn a technique of playing and
then all of a sudden it opens a whole
new element or a whole new realm of
possibility yeah of types of songs you
can now do because you learned a new
technique and from that you know now
it's just like oh well now you added
another superpower to your
ability yeah and and that's again with
film making like it's it's such a it's
hard like it's interesting like we call
film making art form the same way we
would call drawing or something but like
film making is so many art forms like
compiled into one so there's so many
like uh I don't know like skill trees
that you can invest in with with film
making like just on the visual side in
in the VFX world like we specialize in
like specific things with with CG and
visual effects but like there's cameras
there's freaking you know lenses that go
on those cameras and there's like people
who specialize in the most specific like
versions of you know the stop motion guy
like who's the stop motion guy out there
who's like yo the that's the guy that
does all the stop motion shorts that
just slap you know this is that's the
guy there's a guy and he's doing it
right
now you know
yeah but yeah so
yeah I don't know man yeah well I guess
that answers that
question I guess uh it's about being
open
to what you have available I think
that's almost more important all
that's gotten us through more times
than either of the specific approaches
you're right that's the best constraint
is you just look around and be like what
do I have that I could shoot with right
now can I WR a story that includes that
right now that's that's what dictates
our weekly videos to almost every extent
like because we you know we brainstorm
every week we write down ideas then
every Monday it's like okay well what
can we shoot right right now what can we
shoot this week yeah right now and you
look at your list like I can shoot this
like all right that's the one you know
and you can say that on the biggest
budget movie films too it's like you
could have this idea but the day of and
it's cloudy it's like practically what
can we do do we move it or do we do this
or you know do we use a drone or do we
get it it comes down to what can we do
practically no matter if it's a YouTube
video or if it's going to be in a movie
theater yeah they would never risk being
subjected to The Winds of
weather they create their own
weather maybe and we so we filmed an
episode of react today and somehow the
whole episode just ended up being us
looking at effect shots of what
basically just ends up being the actor's
face cut out and put onto a CG shot you
know whether it's Marvel or daging or
just straight up the visual effects
they're doing like it's every single
thing we looked at ended up being a
cutout face on a CG body um Little
Mermaid was one of the things I like
that and like
like I like the the notion of an actor
has like gotten really deconstructed for
me in a weird way now and I'm I it makes
me wonder where it's going because you
have these personalities that
are you know IPS Brands they are
characters right like Brad Pit there is
a human being named Brad Pit but more
specifically there is a creature named
Brad Pit that is the collective point of
everybody's like Charisma perception
creating this being that they think
should exist named Brad Pit
yeah and like that's a different entity
than the actual man like it's most
perfectly visualized in the Legends of
the Fall obviously right exactly what's
that dude is that a Brad Pit movie yeah
oh dude it's like that's like young long
hair
Brad oh man Jake's favorite yeah my f
everyone's favorite Brad you know like
1994 anyway oh that's early bread uh
what was his first one it was like a
that on guys this isn't a Brad this
isn't a brad
podcast I am going somewhere with this
sorry we're just so in love with Brad P
well exactly right it's it's that face
it's that face that they will film and
then cut out and put an entire CG world
and body around and it's just like like
I was asking this questions like why why
are we like doing all like we why why
are they doing all this work and filming
all this just to cut out a little
oval-shaped patch in the center of it
then replace everything else yeah that's
how I've always felt about the Marvel
movies is like I I've really started to
thinking about this recently is like
superhero movies are much better suited
for animation yeah and they are
essentially animated films but because
of the fact that they have to put Robert
Downey Jr's face in these movies all the
CG has to look real but like imagine
like you just don't have Robert Downey
Jr now it can look like spiderverse yeah
and it can be the perfect version of it
because you know we're all big anime
fans like
anime is an adaptation of Japanese comic
books and that's it's a direct
adaptation like those the shows to the
shot yeah yeah the shows have the style
of those books and our adaptations of
our Collective comic book mythology is
like a bunch of people in these like
kind of realistic versions of it but it
still looks goofy you know it's not it's
not again we're talking about looking
for the perfect idea I feel like that
way of doing it unless it's like there's
brief moment where like you had like 300
and Sin City like the Frank Miller
adaptations where like American comic
books are getting their like cinematic
style and then they like it just fell
out and like Marv funny you're you're
absolutely right about that because I
was at my buddy's place this weekend and
his kid had a painting you know like one
of those non-painting paintings that you
can get online of Iron Man oh in his it
was like a painting of Iron Man like you
know looking all stoic and cool and I
and I I stopped and I thought about that
for a second and just about the cultural
significance of this 16-year-old having
a painting of Iron Man in his
room and you know and it was it was a
little bizarre but I totally get why
that's the coolest thing ever to him
because yeah and I feel like that first
Iron Man movie like those first couple
Marvel movies it makes sense for to be
live action it makes sense for it not to
be an animated film because like for the
most part the stakes are kind of real in
terms of like the human characters like
if this guy falls he could hurt himself
like in the most basic way yeah but now
these movies like it'll be like oh the
bad guys coming and they all their
costumes just start like like melting
over their skin and they're like we're
ready to go and it's like it has become
a complete Saturday morning cartoon yeah
and just make it a cartoon then and then
we the stakes the stakes will make sense
like the little oval of face that you're
saving and then you could go you could
go even more grandiose with the
events even more you know they could be
fighting in space for the literally the
entire time well and yeah it's
interesting how in a cartoon that it
sort of like makes more sense sometimes
because this is kind of in the weeds but
the new they have this new Star Wars
show called Ahsoka and Ahsoka uh is a
character from The Animated show and the
in the show spoiler alert they have a
flashback so in the show that she's
originally from it's called The Clone
Wars she is like I guess like 14 years
old but when you're watching the show
it's an animated show so this kid
running around in like a war zone is
like ah it's cute and fun CU it's like
she's bouncy yeah she's bouncing yeah
you know she's like it's a cartoon but
so they have the flashback in this
liveaction series and now because of the
medium you look at it and you're like
wait a second she's like a Child Soldier
and this is like this is really dark and
it's like because they light it in a in
a way it looks like a Vietnam movie and
like Anakin's like come on Ahsoka it's
like why did you take this 14-year-old
into like combat scenarios and she's
like supposed to be the commander of
this Army why is the Viet Kong arming
arming her with an AK-47 what's going on
here and uh I yeah I feel like that with
a lot of these Marvel movies where it's
like um I didn't see the new Ant-Man but
they brought out do you guys know who
modok is in the Marvel Comics he's like
basically uh people might know this
refence from Spy Kids like George
Lopez's character is like in this head
in a jar that it's like it's a giant
like Tech screen with arms and legs and
he's just a giant head um that's modok
in the comics and again as an
illustration oh that's a cool idea as a
liveaction thing it looks like ass you
know yeah and um yeah there's this it's
a uncanny area that we're in with these
superhero movies and with all with all
big budget Blockbusters because like I'm
I'm sure the Transformers movies or
whatever you know big budget thing is
the same thing where it's like here's a
giant CG battle scene and then here's
this guy's face like kind of in there
somewhere top I mean that's basically
Avatar so you know I P I started posing
a question because like I'm trying to
get into like the psychological
underpinnings of it like these weird
human nature things and you know Sam and
Jordan answered of course well human
faces are really hard to do so might as
well just film a real human face we can
do everything else right but when you're
looking at a shot and it's a closeup of
a person currently everybody almost
always fails at doing CG faces
especially when they're a close-up so
you might as well just film a real face
and work backwards from there it's like
okay okay sure you know it makes sense
to me at first but then yeah but then
part of me pauses and be like once again
animated movies are popular do we why do
we really just need that little circle
of a face outside of like oh you know
well it's hard to do it in CG it's like
sure but what if it was just slightly
stylized why do why do we need Robert
Downey Jr's face yeah like as pixels as
pixel the we got to contracts Nico we've
got to have cont it comes down to this
and it's the we fall in love with people
and that's what we've always been
obsessed with celebrities and obsessed
with people and
G is it going to be the same without g g
is it gonna be the same without Paul rud
it's just like I don't know maybe but I
don't think they want to get rid of
those faces America's funny guy at the
party that you don't know but he seems
all right Paul
Rudd yep the sheer economics of the
whole like press junket thing uh it's
changed animated films as well which I
guess it kind of flips the point because
essentially like now because of social
media all this like when the they all go
on the Press junket not only are they
like oh I'm on Channel 5 News they're on
BuzzFeed they're on you know freaking GQ
they're on all these things that people
actually watch on YouTube as just like
regular content and that stuff is so
important in the like engine of the
marketing of these movies so that's
really what the actors are there for
these days in my opinion is like not so
much like there's times where people
will be on the Press tour and they're in
all these goofy BuzzFeed videos where
it's like oh we're with puppies or
whatever I'm like that person's in the
movie for five seconds it's like you
have secret life of pets where they did
like you know Kevin Hart and that's a
really big name and they added like Kim
Kardashian in it and so you do get
people to come listen to those voices
but it only it only goes so far it's
like okay but when you have Marvel and
these faces and who's going to be the
face of Smart Water for the next 10
years and then who's going to do that
new Dior campaign that's worth billions
of dollars that just keeps going Z it's
like you yeah it's the faces and then
the products the advertising the
marketing that comes after it and it
kind of stops when you have an animated
it's it's true it does stop when it's
animated that's a very good point you
can't really meet Miles
Morales yeah not really and that yeah
but that is interesting how it is so
it's an industrial complex it's like a
it's like
yeah but but animated films didn't used
to be like that which I I think is why
it's an interesting case study because
animated films used to be you just get a
voice actor kenberg changed it yeah with
shark tail yes that was the first one
that was the first one where it was like
here's everybody yeah like why is Will
Smith in a cartoon and why does he look
like Will
Smith look like Will
Smith like Kevin Hart doesn't look like
Kevin Hart and pet and secret life of
pet Will Smith looks like Will Smith and
that's what made everyone love the movie
that's they made money and I guess you
like maybe Toy Story would be like and
Shrek was the other one by the way yeah
I think yeah honestly well DreamWorks
like DreamWorks as Studios ant Shrek
Shrek yeah but they were like the they
were the like corporate of D what if we
let's reboot it and call it shrex shre
there's
multiple well JC as as somebody who's an
actual practicing actor you know let me
ask you like so we're at this point
where yeah sure it's hard to do faces
still five years from now I don't think
it's going to be hard to do faces I
think five years from now it won't be
hard to put any face you want in a movie
just straight up whether it's closeup
shots wide shots Etc like I mean it'll
be somewhat difficult I don't think like
you know a kid with her computer could
do it necessarily but this idea of
having something like you know Robert
Downey Jr having his face and no one
else has his face that's going to stop
being a thing where like anybody can
have anybody's face right so JC let me
me ask you as as an actress if you were
in roles where your full performance
could come through right or you're asked
to be in a movie where full performance
full Nuance all that would come through
but it doesn't look like you and it
doesn't sound like you to what extent
does that diminish if at all like your
desire to do that role or that
character I mean that's that's
interesting because there's so many
levels because it's like you have like
the Robert down juner where it's like
his face and then the robot is like
that's not really him really you could
be doing anything and then there's also
you know voice acting where I have full
control over that emotion but they'd
never see me but if you're super popular
they know that it's you and they're like
oh she's a really good voice actor yeah
in this case it be like you're a puppet
master effectively puppeting a fully
detailed flesh out human that's
indistinguishable from
you there's a movie called Pacific Rim
that uh or I mean like would you be like
no thanks or be like yeah it's whatever
it's just a character it's like if
you're an avatar but it's it's people
instead of blue people you know it's
like it's you're just you're uh freaking
uh Dean Arnold you're Arnold
Schwarzenegger you know you can
everything in your face can control
Arnold Schwarzenegger and your and your
voice will change to be Arnold schwarzer
yeah it it it will change the why you
want to act I think I think if like
you're being someone else's persona it's
interesting because it's like you want
to
storytellin and bring what you have to
the table to present to the rest of the
world so it's like to go through someone
else's face would be
interesting it doesn't give the same
effect internally but there's like you
know we have makeup you know we have Pro
Prosthetics that we do um it's
interesting because like yeah it is it's
a theoretical technology because right I
guess there's another question of could
it ever be that good where it could
actually pick up all the nuances of what
your face is doing because of course it
can yeah it it'll get there is there
something about like also the structure
of your specific face that is part of
the the Expressions you're making you
know what I mean like does that
expression change on another person's
face so it's like I'm acting in the
whole film The Marriage story but it's
Scarlet Johansson's face is what you're
basically Yes except let's assume it's
not another actor or actress's face but
just a character that doesn't exist like
they've invented a and assume it's
perfectly interpolated so that there's
no like loss you know from your face to
the to the dis to the displayed
face it's
weird it's definitely weird but it's
like it's just
another it's another job you know it's I
think you can still bring your own
emotions to the table and it's like and
if you love being on set and you love
making films then you're going to love
doing that as well it's like sometimes
to take the shitty jobs it's obviously
not going to be like the job that an
actor who wants to be a superstar is
going to want but you're going to take
it until you don't have to do those type
of jobs anymore and there are like some
people like some people want to be that
background actor or like the stunk guys
that never have their face shown you
know it's like those jobs will exist
yeah but yeah I think they'll be
reserved for the big budget stuff yeah
because like you know like Tarantino has
something he says about which I think is
dumb but he says like uh to him a movie
like if it's not captured if like the
vast majority of the thing is not
captured in a camera of the real world
he's like it's not a movie it's
something else and I think animation
then yeah and I think that's that's
really what we're talking about is like
kind of this new form of anime but it's
so yeah it's weird he gets triggered
about filming with digital cameras
though yeah
but it's
so it's so limiting I think to go into
this space where we're like we're going
to make CG films but we're going to try
to make them look like real life
whereas isn't it so much more exciting
if we just maintain that
like we're like we're always going to
want to make real quote real movies in
terms of like something shot through
camera but this new emerging art form uh
like
I mean it it is at the end of the day
animation like animation is changing
it's not really like film making is
changing uh in the traditional sense
it's that there's new forms of Animation
that you can make look like whatever you
want because there's no limitations like
the the limitation used to be you could
pretty much only do 2D cell shaded
animation because it's cheap to produce
and can be executed in like two years
but now with you know all the tools that
are coming out it's like you can make it
look like whatever you want so well
there was something that
happened and I think maybe the same
thing is happening here now but the
thing that happened when we first
started doing
YouTube was everyone kept trying to
Define it in terms that they were
already familiar with I mean remember
this Nico it went on for years and tell
and now it's not a thing anymore now you
just say oh you're a YouTuber or a
Creator or an influencer or whatever
there's many terms for
it uh but for a long time everyone kept
we would have these conversations to be
like so you're making videos okay and
then you're putting them on the Internet
okay and then people are watching those
videos okay so how long are
they you know and then and uh what did
you use to film them okay uh do do you
like went from one to the next is there
like some consistency or and and and and
we didn't have terms for it or anything
we were just making videos and and the
same thing we're kind of going through
something similar now where we're we're
dealing with this I mean it's going to
be a new thing it'll be a new thing
like yeah is it animation sure I guess
so maybe not there's people who say it's
not I don't know does it matter I guess
on some level it's all kind of becoming
the same thing because I've noticed this
with with films is like they're getting
longer and longer and I heard James
Cameron talking about these new Avatar
movies and he's like there's so much
story I want to tell and there's going
to be like maybe we can do a version
that's on the streamers that's like five
hours I'm like okay so now he's making a
TV show but now all the TV shows are
starting to look like movies when did
every wait when did everyone start
calling them streamers can we get that
straight out real quick cuz that's
that's like the last 6 months really I
always streaming platforms or it was
always streaming service streaming
Platformers streamers were people who
streamed video games yeah or or any any
other thing online but then the industry
the traditional industry started calling
streaming platforms streamers I don't
like that it's just confusing as all
because there's two there's two words
now for two SE there's one word for two
sep things I'm an old man I don't like
change I also don't like corporations
like adopting like us internet you know
users our word streamer I guess I'm an
old corporate
guy but anyway sorry you're saying
streamers would be like a a guy who like
live streams yeah like on a twitch or
the stuff they do gam anywhere else
typically gaming but twitch even has
gone beyond gaming now and just but
Netflix a streaming there's some weird
you can get into the weird Dums of the
internet dumb when you go into streaming
worlds I mean there's you know there's
people who will like there's ASMR
streams there's game streams there's
anyways video game streams can you
believe that people watch people play
video games on the internet and make a
lot of
money you people watch
things hey uh so unfortunately uh ladies
and gentlemen I have to get heading home
uh to have dinner I wasn't expecting I
you got you got like a family or
something Nico you got to go take off
see your children and your wife come on
God damn it we're streamers ni we got to
do this we got to do this at 4:00 a.m.
that's the only way that it's really
always stream if I'm not streaming I'm
losing that's dude no like the sorry I'm
just gon to Quick rant quick rant 30
seconds perfect why why is it that you
have to live the like least healthy
lifestyle possible to be a successful
streamer why is that why is that well
it's it's cuz it's meant for teenagers
and Jin z i cuz there's plenty of people
from our gen well maybe your there's
plenty Millennials that do it too I
think the mass majority it's getting
like you you have to think about it it's
like where when six-year-olds weren't in
our world now they all are it's like
everyone has a phone and a tablet and
it's like it's becoming much younger
like them being a part of our world now
and so I think with everything it's like
how can we cater to the 17year olds and
now it's like the 15y old how can we how
can we keep them up until 4:00 a.m. yeah
I'm talk [__] about streamers all my
streamer friends out there you know I'm
just D maybe Jake the answer is that if
you became a streamer in the first place
your health your lifestyle Health wasn't
all that great to begin
with there something to be said for that
yeah chicken before the egg all I'm just
kidding kind of uh what's up Eli I hope
you're listening
[Laughter]
all right I have to bip I have to B all
right we'll with
you Bippity bity everybody thanks for
listening thanks for watching and we'll
see you on the next
one all right